[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors la semaine dernière le petit
mayombo qu'on embrasse fort m'a fait la
surprise de venir depuis le gab mais je
vous le dis c'est vrai ça a été
magnifique à l'avenir des chalets on
arrêtera ses magloire j'ai adoré l gdi
ben non non ça serait le fils mais on a
adoré la voie et c'est quand même moi
qui a mené la vie dure
donc je suis champion non alors
finalement on a destitué il ya des
règles précises on ne peut pas amener
quelqu'un c'est donc la vidéo daz à
l'édifice cartonnettes et du barca sur
les réseaux est vrai qu'avant j'étais
capable de me donner une phrase où il ya
les mots et du fils au nom du père et du
fils et du saint-esprit en était sérieux
mais il faut situer cette semaine ce qui
va y avoir un nouveau champion vidéo
c'est quoi c'est pas trés tapis de
course comme tu peux le 2 comme tu l'as
fait tapis de course ou et détruit une
nouvelle utilisation du tapis de course
ça et je garde la banane grâce à ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
un non le corps à la virus c'est sûr et
certain qu'ils ont eu pour l'instant pas
mal du tout ça là bas et moi très pour
moi c'est là suffisent et difficile aux
guichets à mes jetons mais j'adore mais
difficile à comme alone à laurence aller
loin regardez ce qu'on va le vent bien
des images vous le savez on est en
pleine période d'ascq à cause du coran
na waie le masque maintenant commence à
faire peur on s'écarte bahia do the mask
qui font encore plus peur regarder voilà
là il va garder le 15
[Musique]
on crée vote pas mal c'est pas mal ans
allez on a maintenant clara bonsoir car
l'appétit new way meshoe c'est lolo je
n'arrive pas je commence à m'inquiéter
rappelle moi il a écouté les messages et
mon avis c'est mon ami de tous mais
c'est vrai que c'est son ami ça l'aurait
ferreira michou c'est toujours vrai
ouais ça se voit il n'ya pas bien oui en
plus ça va sonner je crois que oui le
portable dans le b c c'est une tradition
quelle équipe être parent ça change la
vie ça vaut bouleversé émotionnellement
et passe ça peut aussi surprendre
regardez merci
les fans auront pas bien le cas ouais
moi j'ai un une imitation un imitateur
tout simplement qui est pas mal
d'ailleurs
c'est un très bon bruitages ça s'est
passé lundi après-midi entre 15 et 16
heures lundi dernier à bombay sa clio
rapaces permet de coincer notamment
téléthon bonhomie délais mon fils mon
équipe parce que tu le vois pas avec
iphone klaxons
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est à voir mais si un jour
défendre ma vidéo je suis désolé édifice
est de la recherche et quelques pas
devant des édifices de faire le klaxon
voilà je peux faire moi je suis mes bas
bien élitiste et 10 alors les plus
grandes
instagram heuzé influence euse ne sont
pas nécessairement celles auxquelles on
peut penser n'est ce pas cirer oui bien
sûr et c'est le roi jean voyez vous je
vais même plus mettre les images du raid
que les longs mois est ce que tu peux
nous le faire bien sûr le disais les
plus grandes installera meuse et
influence us ne sont pas nécessairement
celles auxquelles on pense lancer les
images alors encore une fois le tough le
tort tu as vu cette qualité de cheveux
c'est donc ce que t'as vu c'est que je
parte il finira par [ __ ] j'ai rien n'y
en a pas eu de jojoba et c'est beau
merci de répondre à qualité tu veux leur
dire merci un chef exceptionnel allez ta
vidéo boulot alors alors
d'aucuns diront oui oui les gels
lubrifiants ont progressé dans
l'atteinte ou de même des limites de la
sodomie croissance mans je crois qu'on
apprend capeletto le patron de ses
mythes qui veut
à danser le sujet qu'on a fait en moins
de la partie vidéo cela salariale est
allé au dessus des dix fils pour la voir
une fois pas venir d'idées à chasser le
naturel
alice génial ça nous fait hyper bizarre
d'avoir des nouvelles demandes à lire je
pense qu'elle est championne qu ai je
rêvé le lot c'est au bas non non c'est
non merci à l'échoppé de regarde
eric à la fin de ces femmes la dame elle
appelle ses fans l'adorent ares est
meilleur c'est la meilleure voilà le
nouveau champion
[Applaudissements]